[Music]
richie
in raleigh north carolina what's up
brother richie how are we doing man
hey rich sir uh dr deloney good morning
i'm really nervous sorry about that hey
i am too man i i'm still
i when's the last time you crushed
a sleeve of cookies man ah
i think it's been a few months at least
see talking to people with self-control
is
it's good for me hey so what's up
brother thanks for calling man how can i
help dude
oh thank you dr delany first of all
thank you so much for taking my call i
really do appreciate it sir
um my name is richie i live here in
raleigh um i'm a marine corps veteran
i'm originally from a small town up in
ohio
and i've been out of the marine corps
for a few years now um
i i am or i was um
an emotionally abusive boyfriend or
ex-boyfriend
with my ex a few years ago um
and i'm i i've kind of started dating
this
one new girl again i've been out of the
dating scene for a few years and i'm
honestly i'm terrified i'm not really
sure what to expect
uh my relationship with my parents is
not very good at all
um i i started going to church but
that's
i mean that's hit or miss that's a whole
other
conversation right yeah honestly
um but i'm i'm terrified i don't want to
repeat this
i've been going to therapy for a little
over a year now okay
and um so what what yeah what does well
number one dude
just uh you've done some brave things in
your day and this is probably
up there at the top um i've run around
with guys i've been a part of
swat trainings and worked in the
military i've seen some stuff and heard
some even wilder stories
and there's always components of bravery
but as far as i'm concerned there are a
few
braver things than saying
i'm an emotionally abusive guy and i
don't i want to be different than that
so on behalf of
men everywhere and more importantly
behalf on behalf of the
wives and kids that are subject to that
thank you for being a brave guy
and trying to turn and stare this thing
down appreciate that man
um doesn't excuse you being an idiot
right but
you're a brave guy right so walk me back
a couple things
um how long are you in the in the in the
marine corps man
i just did four years four years what
was your exit rank yeah
i got out as a sergeant okay outstanding
man so did you see combat did you go
overseas what was your roles i went
overseas twice i was motor t
um i was never personally in combat
however i was in
the uh the area if that makes any sense
at all
yeah dude of course hey everybody's on
the team man
everybody's on the team i know there
gets to be a
oh yeah well i will i man you went
overseas and you and you
serve your country brother so i
appreciate that so tell me about
what emotional abusive means what does
that mean to you
what'd you do oh man i i was pulling
manipulative
i lied um oh
for god's sake um it was
i i i became a christian uh if that
matters at all after
we uh after i joined the military and i
was like
teetering the fence of uh hey we
shouldn't be having sex but hey let's go
have sex
you know and and so she was torn because
she was
she i think she believed in god at the
time i'm not even sure anymore
um this is a few years ago now hey
you're cycling out on me though hold on
you're you're doing some excellent
evasive maneuvers
how are you emotionally abusive
oh man um
i made it all about myself i was selfish
i didn't care what she wanted to do i
didn't i wanted
i wanted to please myself in the
relationship
i wanted to if i wanted to go out and
party i was going to go out and party
and leave her behind
um i i it was i
and if i wanted to go see other girls at
the same time i was going to go do that
too
gotcha um so that that makes it makes
that makes it sound more like you're
just a jerk
like just a scummy boyfriend how are you
abusive
did you yell at her did you swear did
you did you put your hands on her how
are you
um abusive
oh like she cried all the time all the
time in the relationship so
and i and this is i i've given my myself
uh like a self-diagnosis if that matters
at all dr daloni um but i've just
i figured that this is all as i reflect
it must have been all emotional abuse
not physical never physical but it was
always manipulation
she was crying all the time even towards
the end of the relationship i was like
listen
i am so unhappy and you are so unhappy
she wanted to stick through the
relationship and i was like this is
bonkers so where did you where did you
pick that up
where did you learn to talk to
somebody in that way where did you learn
that you're
oh man your path was the most important
path
and someone that you love who cares man
um friends family whatever um
virtue uh values screw all that
i'm plowing through with whatever i want
to do
[Applause]
oh man um it it
uh it really
so sorry um no it's all good brother
somebody somebody taught you that
where'd you pick that up
was it mom or was it dad was it the core
where
did you pick it up it was my father it
was my father it it
our relationship basically it became
an exact mirror image of my parents
marriage
uh okay so this is how men treat women
right
yeah literally that was what i knew and
i'm i'm the only guy it was me my dad
and i've got
four sisters so you know it was
i oh man it was awful dumb so
yeah you break up with this with this
woman and
you take some time off why'd you take
some time off
i i felt like i was being suffocated
you were being suffocated yeah
how ironic right it's like it's like you
got both hands around
somebody's neck and you're choking them
to death and you stop choking because
man my hands are sore right like you're
the yeah
you're on the bottom end of this deal so
then you meet somebody and you fall back
in love
and you've already done something stupid
what have you done so far well
i mean i i took some time off from
dating and i've been going to therapy
and now very recently i've started
dating again
yeah but so you've already
violated what you had had you had some
ideas about some pictures about what
this thing was going to look like you've
already screwed those up what have you
already done
oh we're already sleeping together okay
like
if that's what you're getting there no
no no i'm i'm getting it
have you already lied to her have you
already pressured her to do something
she wasn't comfortable with have you
already gone out and seen somebody else
when you
this woman thinks y'all are exclusive
have you already yelled at her have you
already
like swore at her flexed on her a little
bit
it's it's the online dating apps is what
it is
i'm chatting up with other with other
women at the same time okay
and so what made you say enough
i want to change man i want to be
different i want to i want to do this
as right as i possibly can i want to
i i'm so this is what i said recently to
my therapist i said i'm so
sick of just putting on a front and
playing pretend
i'm exhausted it's like i'm exhausted
from it
i hope that makes sense but i'm just
like yeah totally i
i i want to be a new person i want to be
a different
person
playing the games is
i don't know like i'm turning 30 soon
you know i can't keep doing this man
yeah like dude i i want something
different i want this change i want this
anything and everything i'm i don't want
to keep repeating my parents marriage
you know that
but it's the only picture of marriage
you got so paint me a picture of what
you want
like what do you want this to look like
oh man um uh white picket fence golden
retriever and 10 million dollars in the
bank account
i don't know um i i i just want us to be
happy together
i know but listen listen when you run
from something
without a direction of where you're
gonna head you don't get anywhere
you just keep replaying the same tape
over and over
and so where yeah do you want to be a
guy who values
his girlfriend who values his wife
that she feels safe around that he can
keep his mouth shut and not
ever ever swear at her
ever yell because yelling is the sign of
a somebody who's lost all control
yelling is what children do
do you want to be a guy who is
trustworthy
and doesn't cheat on
the person that they love i mean is that
what you're looking for
yeah absolutely yeah but you can't say
that why can't you say that
it sounds like a fantasy to me why it
sounds like something it
it's like a hollywood
it's like a hollywood movie fairy tale
lie
um i i see some of these marriages i see
some of these people and they look so
happy together and it's
where's the honesty where's the struggle
where's the hay
or on i i don't know maybe it's because
all my military bodies all of them are
now divorced
they're all under second or third or
fourth marriages like my
when i look at close friends of mine
when i look at my immediate family the
track record is
is a big fat zero and and
that's that's what i that's what i see
that's what i i i know that's what i
uh that that's the the groups of people
i surround myself
with there you go right there right
there
okay that's it so i'll tell you can you
have a great marriage absolutely
does great marriage mean there's never
conflict no anyone who tells you that is
lying to you marriage is hard
real hard
and it's messy and people hurt each
other and they say i'm sorry
and then they don't talk for a day then
they get back together
that's the nature of marriage it's hard
and it's always worth it if you got two
people invested in making the other
person's life as good as possible
and when you look at what you want in
your life and you haven't done that
you know what you don't want you you
know the hollowness of the life you're
in right now
the hard work is figuring out what it is
you do want and here's why that's hard
to do because once you nail it down
then you know there's a gap between an
unmet mission
and how you're choosing to live
and that's the difference up between you
now you're able to just roll your eyes
and say it's just the way it always is
and this always happens this way
once you say i want this now you know
you got to go get it
and choosing not to go get it is a
choice and that falls on you
and then you can't blame your old man
you can't blame your buddies you can't
blame the system you can't blame people
lying to you blah blah blah
you've got to do the hard work of saying
this is what i want and then you got to
go make that happen
it's the same as if you want to lift
weights it's the same if you want to
become a better shot
it's the same if you want to move up to
sergeant you got to do these things to
get there
and then when you look around at the
people around you
if you know wood doesn't sharpen iron
so you got to get a better group of
people to hang out with and i know a
bunch of veterans with
impeccable marriages that are hard and
messy
and full of forgiveness and full of
starting over almost on a weekly basis
but i don't buy that because you're in
the military because you're
hard because you've seen stuff that you
can't have a good marriage that's not
true
it's not and so that means
it it the question's going to come down
to how bad do you want this
how bad do you want to be able to sleep
all night
without medication how bad you want to
be able to get up in the morning how bad
do you want somebody that's gonna be
ride or die with you and you her how bad
do you want kids
that are gonna love you and respect you
and not be running around when they're
30 trying to figure out how to love
somebody
how bad you want that and then it's
relatively simple moving forward and
it it makes me sound like callous right
because it's um
how do you lose weight diet and exercise
man it's hard it's simple but it's hard
right yeah this is very similar
starting today you will
never ever lie to a girlfriend again
period ever
you will never yell or swear or be
disrespectful again
you may have to walk out the front door
and take a walk around down the
neighborhood
you may have to cut somebody off on the
phone and say hey i need to hang up
and i'll call you back in five minutes
and then hang up the phone
you got to do what you have to do but
you have to decide
starting today i will never do this
again
and when you fail what you will you will
catch yourself in the middle of a lie
and you'll stop and say hold on hold on
i did go see somebody last night and i'm
sorry
i did or on your way to go see somebody
you will stop and you'll text that
person say i'm not coming i'm actually
in a committed relationship and you'll
turn on and go home
or in the middle of yelling or in the
middle of trying to talk somebody into
sleeping with you again when she doesn't
want to
you'll stop and say hey i actually value
your values
you'll stop here's what i want you to do
i want you to get a a small
picture of your old man and
every time you yell or cheat or lie
i want you to pull that picture up and i
want you to look at it
and i want you to say hey man i value
you more than her
every time
because that's what you're choosing at
this point you're choosing to to
walk a path that your old man cut for
you in the woods he didn't do a very
good job
and i don't want to be in the business
of running down people's dads but he
didn't do a good job
it's way harder to carve a new path and
so i want you to carry that with you for
a while
and it's just it's just choosing you
know what dad i'm gonna follow you man
i value you more than her i value you
more than
my future kids i'm gonna have
and at some point you're gonna have to
forgive yourself for the
jerk that you were and you haven't done
yet that yet either
you carry that around with you a lot
yeah every day and so it's when you have
uh
you may have heard me talk about this
there's you should feel guilty
when you swear at your girlfriend you
should because that's
garbage it's trash it's what children do
you should feel guilty when you yell at
somebody you feel guilty when you lie to
him
there's a difference between losing your
cool
not having the tools in your tool kit
and
saying i lied to you versus i'm a liar
right that's when you decide to put that
brick of guilt in your backpack and
carry it around with you forever
and that's what you've done i'm a liar
i'm a cheater
i'm a scumbag i'm just like my old man i
always will be this is the way this is
going to be forever and the more you
carry that around
all that baggage comes with you and of
course your knees always hurt and your
back always hurts and you don't want to
have to learn any new things you're
carrying all this crap around you got to
set that down man
okay you gotta set it down let's go
carrying him
i need you in my community a whole
well guy i need you going to the gym
i need you still training in some sort
of
you know kickboxing you just i need you
still taking care of yourself
i need you still having male friends in
your life good ones that will hold you
accountable
are you still trying to get better i'm
proud of you for going to counseling
dude that's hard to do
but it sounds like you i know folks who
go to counseling for a year and they
just become complaint sessions
and the counselor is happy to take your
money
and you need to get with somebody that
will call your bluff and hold you
accountable
okay but here's the thing brother i am
i'm i am just blown away by your bravery
to even have this conversation and i
have 1
000 confidence in you because i've seen
it before
tell me about this girl you're dating
we uh we met on an online dating app
um and we just hit it off really well
okay
um i
i think we are very emotionally
based people um
i mean which emotions i guess they're
not bad but it's intimidating
um i i try to be as logical as i can but
anyway
um she's a really nice girl she's a
nurse full-time so she works a lot
um i don't know we love to laugh
we love to spend time together um we're
very intimate a lot
i will say um
she has experienced some trauma in her
life as well
not from her parents but from
from an ex-boyfriend i don't know too
many details about that i didn't ask i
didn't want to press in i wasn't sure if
it was
true the right place or time to ask her
about that
those those conversations will come in
due time the more you prove that you're
trustworthy
and that you're safe and one of the sad
facts about people who are traumatized
and relationships full of trauma
is the body craves homeostasis man
it knows that track and it will go find
that track again
and so it doesn't surprise me that
somebody who's experienced trauma finds
another guy who's skilled in trauma
right yeah and so i
i like like you i like emotions
but they are directional they're not um
they don't often tell me the truth right
they let me know i'm not okay they're
alarm systems but they don't tell me the
truth
so when you get emotional i want you to
write that stuff down man get that crap
out of your head and onto a piece of
paper
and then go through it and say is this
true or is this not true
am i really angry with her am i or am i
just scared i'm going to screw this up
and then when you can look at somebody
that you care about and say hey i'm
scared i'm going to screw this up
because i've screwed this up every time
in the past
and thank you for letting me say these
words out loud and it's embarrassing for
me because i'm a hardcore
marine corps vet but i'm learning i'm
practicing i'm trying
i don't know how to love you other than
just to hug and
at some point y'all become when you have
a nurse who's dealing with trauma all
day and you're
a guy who has dealt in trauma your whole
life and you're still on fight or flight
still run and run
there becomes this man you all become a
um a bandage for one another right until
you both bleed through the bandage and
then you gotta rip it off and go find
somebody else find a new bandage and you
become somebody else's new bandage
i want you guys to heal from the inside
out
man you deserve that man you deserve
that richie i hate what was happening
what happened to you as a kid i hate
that model you got
and i hate that you've hurt people but
man i'm proud of you for saying no more
decide decide i will never yell again
i will never lie again i will always be
on time
and as you lean into those truths i will
never
yell by the way anybody out there who
yelled you're a child
a child who gets so mad i have to raise
my voice that means you've completely
lost control of yourself
and anybody you're trying to lead
yelling instantly turns people into
fight or flight
all they are thinking about at that
point is how do i get out of this
situation
towards safety quit learning
quit trying to connect
but i'm gonna say no more i'm gonna say
no more
and i think you can richie if you decide
so i want you to go to your counselor
and say
i'm making some declarations and i need
some accountability and i want to work
on accountability with you and if your
counselor says well how does it make you
feel just get up and walk out and go
find somebody else
you're better than that you need
somebody better than that but i'm proud
of you brother
i'm proud of you now it's time to go do
the hard work and make change
that starts with deciding where you want
to go where you want to go